covered levels may be rising but
Stockholm's Rush Hour looks very much
like it did before the pandemic that
normalcy like in most cities around the
world is partly due to the global
vaccination program
a program that received reflected glory
in the Swedish capital on Monday as two
of its Pioneers were awarded the most
prestigious Prize in science the Nobel
assembly at carolinsky Institute it has
today decided to award the 2023 Nobel
Prize in physiology or medicine jointly
to Catalin carrico and Drew Wiseman
kerryco and Wiseman developed the MRNA
vaccine that allowed a rollout of
inoculations against covid-19 within a
year of the disease emerging
but it had been a long struggle we
couldn't get funding we couldn't get
Publications we couldn't get the early
people to notice RNA as something
interesting and it had failed clinical
trials and pretty much everybody gave up
on it but you know give Katie lit the
match and and we spent the rest of I
don't know 20 plus years working
together figuring out how to get it to
work I didn't know whether it is real
you know Mr swipe is maybe some you know
maybe I I don't know that may not have
been an unrealistic assumption given the
relative speed with which the pair have
been awarded their 1 million dollar
prize it can take very many years
sometimes decades for the Nobel
committee to recognize the work of a
scientist in the case of Catalan carico
and Drew Weissman is just under three
years since their breakthrough made a
decisive impact in the fight against
covid-19 it is rapid but the vaccine
that was so important to save lives was
actually grounded on of basic finding in
basic research 15 to 20 years back
and that's I think important to people
to understand that is very important to
have the tools in the toolbox when
something unexpected happened as the
pandemic
mRNA allowed a vaccine to be developed
that didn't need a weakened version of
the coronavirus to be injected into
patients
it could now be used to fight other
diseases such as cancer
it's also given its Pioneers a place in
medical history Paul Reese Al Jazeera
Stockholm
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera